the first thing we'll do is add
functionality to create conferences
here's the creative conference page in
the UI for the web app you see you enter
the name the city the description if we
were to go ahead and enter these values
now the conference wouldn't get created
because this page sends a call to the
create conference function and it's
going to be your job to implement that
function but it's not implemented yet
we're going to create conference
entities in such a way that each one has
a parent and that parent is a profile of
the user who created it the reason for
doing this is it makes it very easy to
quickly find all the conference's that a
particular user created for example
you'll be able to very quickly find all
the conference's that you created now
let's take a look at the code so here i
have the class conference and you'll see
that it has this at parent property
using objectify the way you create an
entity with a parent is that you use the
annotation at parent to annotate one
property as the parent so in this case
we've annotated profile key as the
property that's going to hold the parent
so profile key is going to be the key of
the profile entity that's the parent of
this conference now when you created
profile entities you specified user ID
as a property to use as the ID for
conference entities we don't have any
specific thing that we can use as the
key that uniquely identifies the
conference so we're going to let App
Engine allocate the key for us however
using object Phi you still need to
identify one property as the property to
hold the ID so in this case we're going
to use the cunningly named property ID
and mark it as a tidy so this is the
property that uses the ID for the key if
you remember for profile entities the ID
property was a string and here for
conference it's a long that's long with
an L there's three kinds of types that
your property annotated by a tidy can be
can be a long capital L long little L or
string capital s so one more annotation
that we didn't use in the profile class
is that index
you'll notice that some of the fields in
the conference have this at index
annotation and what that means is we
want to index a property and the reason
we do this is that later on we're going
to be searching on that property we're
going to be searching on the name for
example we won't be searching on the
description so what I'm going to do is
just quickly scroll through this code
and explain what it does we already
talked about the app parent the profile
key is the key of the parent of this
entity topics every conference can
optionally have one or more topics that
it's about for example your conference
might be about medical innovations or
web technologies or maybe it's about
both web technologies and programming
languages so this is a multivalued
property it's a list of strings we have
the city we have the start date of the
conference the end date we're also going
to keep track of the month so that we
can issue query such as show me all the
conferences in December so the max
attendees is the maximum capacity of the
conference we're also going to have the
seats available which keeps track of how
many seats are still available obviously
at the very beginning the seats
available is the same as the capacity
but as people sign up to attend the
conference these seats available is
going to go down for entities in general
the default constructor is private and
here we have the constructor for the
conference and what this constructor
does is it sets the ID to pass then ID
and it also figures out the profile key
by calling key or create on profile it
also figures out the profile key of the
parent profile and sets it and then it
just sets the organizer user ID and then
it calls this update with conference
form to set the other values in the
conference here we've got some getter
methods get the profile key here this
get web safe key just basically returns
a string of the conference's key so that
it can be passed around through forms
and through the browser if necessary and
this one here the get organizer display
name the display name is calculated on
the fly when we need it just in case the
organizer updates their display
name okay just some more Gators get
topics we get a defensive copy of the
list get City we need to get the start
date the end date get month and so on
the update with conference form method
takes values sent in the conference form
and updates conference entity with those
values for example here you see how we
calculate which month conference is
occurring in and set the value of the
month field there's a couple more
methods that will be using later there's
book seats so that when a user register
attend the conference we need to keep
track of how many seats are available so
we decrease the number of seats
available by the number booked and then
give back seats if someone registers for
conference and changes their mind and
unregistered then we need to reset the
seats available and then this two
strings just a function so that you can
get a string of the entire conference
now we actually wrote all the code for
conference Java for you I want you to
make sure that you take a look and read
it and understand it now let's take a
quick look at the conference form class
again we've written this class for you
this class defines the input parameters
to the create conference function just
like profile form define the input
parameters to the function save profile
so basically contains the fields that
are going to be passed in the form or
whatever input method to the create
conference function and if you're
getting worried that we wrote too much
for you don't worry you're going to be
writing the create conference method
yourself